[Music]
in buy drinks news submitted by attack
of the Bayeux a bar owner says customers
who only order tap water are ruining her
business well that's rude yeah why
coming to my bar and asked for a glass
of water
was that what she's saying that makes
sense because if they're not buying
alcohol is probably going down because
whenever I asked for water I try to tip
the bartender and then the bartender
goes no well what's going on in this bar
that they're only asking there's that
many people maybe she doesn't know how
to make drinks the tap is probably
really good all she's overreacting like
a few people asked for water and she's
like [ __ ] you or it's like really good
water like I think it's really delicious
it's like alkaline water it's like I got
to go to that bar cuz that water's
delicious yeah so this bar also serves
food and so she's complaining about the
fact that people who are serving her
getting food aren't also ordering a
drink with their meal we go that's their
choice though Oh weird yeah so so
they're ordering things mm-hmm yeah so
she's saying so this place should be a
[ __ ] Bristol Spirit says is in England
and so she's saying that wish dough at
least 14 people only drink water at the
bar last week and so she's saying if you
come to Bristol spirit and only drink
free tap water we will not make enough
money from your table to break even
let's your fault any profit yeah that's
bad business haven't you in the places
where there's drink minimums that's what
I like shows and comedy club oh that's
what I was thinking about your well
that's that's stupid then you're not
pricing your food right then you know I
only drink water yeah people are
consistently buying food you should make
profit on the [ __ ] food like that her
place is known or like the whole concept
behind it is about drinks she's saying
like if you come here you're pretty much
like insulting us if you order don't
sell food then why'd you [ __ ] sell
food you don't be a complimentary item
to the dreams yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
there's only one part in Game of Thrones
were
how made me laugh say that for later I
just want to say this though but it was
lip this is not a spoiler though who
makes me laugh all the time
it literally looks at Brianna Tarte that
he goes yeah dumb [ __ ] necessary what
the [ __ ] you dumb [ __ ] oh god one of
the writers just wanna had it they
wanted to have a comedy moment he made
me laugh a lot actually
I love the hound he's such he reminds me
my old dog Tyson he needs love like
crazy but he's so [ __ ] aggressive
yeah you can tell he needs love because
his brother abuse he was an abused dog
so it's awesome since I think it's so
funny yeah back to this part owner she
says that they offer around fifty
different options for those not wanting
to drink alcohol and that's what she's
[ __ ] up she has all these options for
all the things she doesn't want to sell
is she like yeah I just don't have
options which she do she talked about
alcohol non-alcoholic drinks or just
food options she's talking about the
fact that yeah is it food options or
non-alcoholic drinks yes she's
complaining cuz she has none on
alcoholic options for people that don't
want to drink she's just she wants
people to either order alcohol or some
sugary ass drink and not get water
that's her whole thing here cuz so
that's why people are like what the [ __ ]
not everyone drinks sugary like like you
like you only drink water or alcohol but
um we got some people are just I don't
think she drinks okay I'm gonna buck a
soda-lime it's not sugary at all
she brought this really long gets you
drunk yeah what about like the one
friend out of the group that doesn't
really like me yeah so she wants you to
order an apple juice or something yeah
so this is actually a lot longer the
whole thing is her complaining about
people who are wearing water how does
this person even have a business I know
sovereign's it reminds me of the Yelp
owners that like respond to every hate
comment and they like get really
passionate like well if you don't like
it you should never come back
blablabla and they like go on a rant
about their whole tax season one heat
comment mm-hmm so like the end the end
of this here it says so if you visit us
and are enjoying the atmosphere the art
the wonderful stab the lovely furniture
the will design menu is that the hugest
suck your own dick lady serious my god
geez and of course I spotless and lovely
kitchen that our chefs rave about
remember all of those things cost
significant money to create the space
was pretty horrible when we'd fight in
the kitchen was a cesspit she sounds
like um I like the internet cuz it helps
people learn some growth she's gonna
learn some right sounds like an Aggie
mom and like the customers are not her
children yeah do they help have Yelp
over there I don't know that's crazy
well this sucks into help well how bad
are their bartenders or their atmosphere
then that people don't want to buy
drinks because I know that for certain
restaurants they make a majority of
their money off the liquor yeah yeah for
sure right but they're not pressing
their food right what doesn't sound like
a very friendly atmosphere yeah you know
what I mean like I don't think I've ever
if like it's like the mood is right in
like a bar or a dining area I'm gonna
drink yeah the moods right yeah it's a
misery if I come in and there's this big
busty lady with a [ __ ] beer stein in
there take I'm drinking it was a big tip
yeah just looking spread amongst maybe
maybe she doesn't have good margins on
the food and she's banking on the
alcohol sales because it's so much more
like once you have a liquor license you
make so much more money so she's just
being greedy she should just get smaller
food like a little tiny like appetizers
yeah tapas bars always have the same
typical [ __ ] really salty really fried
cuz you'll want a [ __ ] drink with it
you know so if you're serving fancy food
most likely your [ __ ] drink tab is
not gonna be that much up anyways or
maybe she shouldn't have opened a bar in
front of a preschool or when scared of
drink just going there for mac and
cheese and [ __ ] and I don't want
triggers the [ __ ] priest clothes yeah
I want to know how bad it is education I
know it's 90% of her customers just
ordering water like how [ __ ] bad is
this you think in front of a church or
something no one wants
it's located inside a preschool for
grilled cheese and tomatoes like how's
the food that good like cuz I that means
people are just going there to eat and
not drink so stop having such good food
that people drink then not yes like with
the meal yeah what you dope about this
lady though is that like it's everyone
else's problem and it's not her yeah I
love narcissism yes you've never
evaluated oh maybe it is my the ambience
here maybe it is my location or maybe
this my margins it's more like nah y'all
are [ __ ] up she's like ordering
waters like I gave you a beautiful
kitchen I'll give you a nice atmosphere
I'll give you a taste
oh yeah so now they're reporting ice is
getting death threat I want some tap
water I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I think you've told me that a few times
yeah but that's different I'm saying
kind of friendly like I can't openly go
out into a woman that I hate a big-ass
tree a dumb [ __ ] while sitting on a
horse to just gallop away they can't do
anything about it
someone commented so you're saying if I
buy three-course meal and order water
that I'm helping to put you out of
business
sugar at dinner buddy yeah you know
you're [ __ ] up when like the comment
is just sensible but a roast the [ __ ]
I know tryin to roast yeah I'll be like
really wholeheartedly like I might think
if I get all this I'm relieving to put
three-course meal what the [ __ ] my baby
is like how do you not see that yeah
you're ordering water duh order a drink
why wouldn't you want to drink Oh weird
woman I love how these kind of people
exist yeah because it's so funny
watching them go [ __ ] balls out it's
all watch I love watching them fail I
wanna know what she looks like is this
[ __ ] just drinking sugar drinks all day
is like does she think no one drinks
water I feel like the restaurants packed
like people buy food is she's still
complaining yeah Steve he hates water
but he loves sugary drinks and alcohol
yeah number one customer yeah she looks
like she likes sugary drinks and that
bar looks like [ __ ] that's exactly why
that's why I know it's buying it bar
looks terrible what are you talking
about it doesn't look like sure what's
the [ __ ] picture little clock this
yeah it's like an abstract art I've
never seen any of those brands and
alcohol before your nipples this is
Britain yeah but still you shouldn't
have like Guinness or like some
standards Steve this is what I mean they
got room-temperature beer in the UK I
hated drinking cold beer
yeah it's like room temp or like
slightly below room temp butter cold Wow
you do like order ice for your beer if
you look cool buddy look at us like
you're weird yeah probably
they think we're weird for putting ice
in our soft drinks and stuff like
Europeans don't do that oh I just do
that that's why they had to play outside
looks like [ __ ] to the inside
description was a great and upscale
ambience in like a nice kitchen what
what did she kind of looks like San
Francisco it does yeah yeah but that
looks like a warehouse of services your
place looks like [ __ ] you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] I like when you smile your [ __ ]
eyeballs get like your eyes get smaller
I could see your eyeballs through her
eyelids
it's [ __ ] cute I know my eyes see
turns out cute I think when we're
shooting sends boobs I hate that we're
doing this picture thing and lay baby
can you open your eyes wider I was like
that's [ __ ] impossible you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do we like these photo shoot stuff
and they wanted me to jump on a
trampoline trampoline to do these fun
shots but I had bad knees and I'm also
200 pounds and they're just like hey can
you like not you know look so scared
stupid asses now open your eyes a little
white or two I was like what you guys
have to realize your wife and I'm Asian
you can't say that I can't do this she
said I can't you dumb [ __ ] a [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
you
[Music]